Carlo three bitches,
you know, which is why,
and Mary goes to the manger. The animals
are not in the manger and not at the,
so there, there's secondary evidence for,
that's probably happened in the spring.
That's how with the advent of commercial
space travel, no seems, seems it
seems inevitable, right? Love you. Love
your segues. Yes. No, don't, don't.
Do you think that it's possible that
maybe you can even offer up a flat earth
believer tour where you,
you take them like at the very least,
take them up to Alaska where it's light.
So 23 hours a day calling into a
tweeting me constantly to me constantly.
Yeah, call me a sellout. I'm a
sellout. I'm a round earth sellout.
Like as if there's some round earth money.
Why are you on the payroll checks?
I'm getting some ground earth,
Earth Pale,
or for your show,
I'm sure you've seen the basketball
player who graduated from Duke,
from Duke was hitting the
news the last couple of days.
I saw the leaves that dinosaurs are
fake and that the world is flat. Okay.
So here's the thing, Joe. Okay. I've
thought about this. I bet you have.
As an educator, I've thought
about this. Okay, so here's,
here's what matters, right?
We live in a free country.
People should be able to think what
ever they want, whenever they want.
Provided it doesn't subtract away
from someone else's rights. Okay?
So thinking the earth is flat doesn't
harm anyone unless you want to run for
office or you want some position
of power over other people.
That's when it's dangerous.
I thinking of elevator of banks
where they have numbers, you know,
I have a photo essay of with
what elevators look like inside.
I know it's just, I mean the
gears and, oh no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, not even that.
Geeky. Just what are the numbers on the
panel? Oh, without the 13 you mean? Yeah,
yeah,
exactly.
So about 80% of buildings taller than
12 stories don't have a 13th floor.
Okay.
And so this tricks a deck,
a phobia is again,
in a free country,
if you, if you want to be afraid
of the number 13 go right ahead.
It just seems to me you should not
be tasked with designing elevators.
If that's your fear,
find something else to do.
Holding aside the fact that I'm a little
scared that in this 21st century United
States of America, we have people walking
among us, afraid of the number 13.
What does that mean? I don't know in the
long run, but if you keep to yourself,
don't harm others,
think what ever you want so that the
rubber hits the road is you now have power
over others.
And that's where the failure of the
educational system actually manifests.
Now when you get in a debate with a guy,
like I don't debate be guy,
I don't debate people. Okay, well
when you discuss the saying goes,
when an argument lasts more than five
minutes, both sides are wrong. Well,
that's a terrible saying.
It was definitely mostly wrong.
And the other person's stubborn can
definitely last for hours. Yeah,
that's not true. It's not, it's true
80% of the time. Okay. Okay. Yeah. Um,
but you got into it with that
wrapper that thinks that the,
here's what I'll tell you why
Bob pause in his Twitter stream,
he was saying he was invoking
physics. And so I, I gotta,
I gotta deal with this. And so he
showed a picture from bear mountain,
which is a mountain and in slightly
upstate New York where Manhattan is in the
sight line of the summit of this mountain.
And he says,
give her the curvature of
the earth and this formula,
you should not be able to see
Manhattan at all. Okay. Um,
and it depends on the height
that you're viewing. Thank
you. Well, well, so, so you,
you do the math and it
turns out Manhattan,
the island would not be visible at all.
That's true.
But any building taller than 15 stories
would rise up above the curvature of the
earth. And you will see it.
And if you look at the photo,
you see the tall buildings
rising above 15 stories,
it's exactly what the correct
formula shows and not his formula,
which was wrong and misinterpreted a
claims to show, well, let's just bizarre,
because snipers had been using the,
the,
the literal curve of the Earth
to plan where bullets go.
That's the one at that precise.
You have to, when you shoot a mile,
you know when you're shooting like
well out over a thousand yards, those,
those factors. So let me
think a mile. I have to ask,
how much curvature of the earth do you get
after mile? Interesting. Drop question.
You get drop and curb. That should
be gravity drop and then curve. Yeah.
So both of those. Yeah. Well is it good?
Well it's here. Here's the thing to say.
Someone if you a have a bullet in
your hand and you shoot a gun, uh,
which the same faster, right? They, yeah,
the generally they get the wrong answer
to that drop at the exact same rate.
They'll hit the ground at the same
time, exact same time. And that,
that blows people's minds. They can't
believe you'd do that in physics 101 it's,
it's an expense. It's a physics demo. So
that's why it's physics is so important.
You know, people, oh, let's
take biology and this great,
but don't leave out the physics because
that's where the fundamental operations
of nature are to be found of the
physical universe are to be found.
So what you have is you
have a gun at one side.
It's like a thing that shoots out of
projectile and we'll call it a gun at one
side of the stage,
and then you have like a little stuffed
animal with the other side's days held
up with an electromagnet
at the top of its head.
And these two are exactly the same level
as the projectile comes out from the
boat. There's many cannon it trips
and electric circuit that releases the
electromagnet at the top
of the stuffed animal.
The stuffed animal begins to fall.
The bullets moves horizontally,
but also falls because gravity is pulling
them both and you watch the projectile
curve down,
you watched the stuffed animal come down
and it hits the stuffed animal every
single time.
The only factor that would change that
would be if you put wings in the bullet.
It was dealing with the wind wanes,
right? Yeah. When, when would affect it?
Yeah. Did they have boats with wings? I
haven't seen that. No, they don't. Okay.
But if they did,
you know,
if like you shot the bullet and then
they figured out like wings came out on
some James Bond movie, I thought,
yeah, I'm sure. Yeah. It's,
it's just gotta be frustrating for you
when these things come back around.
Like there was no flat earth
theory when I was in high school.
So the other things though, think
about it, when you're in high school,
there was much more astrology going
on. Oh yeah. The President Reagan,
Nancy Reagan has an astrologer.
Uh,
so today you don't see much of it
unless you talked to Steve Maxwell,
but it's still there. It's just not,
it's not manifesting in public policy.
Some people believe in it deeply. I agree.
But it's not up there in public policy.
That's what I'm saying.
Okay, well we're the,
Nancy Reagan was really the only one
that made it with public policy then.
But at the bar to do you hear people
saying, what's your sign? Oh hell,
still a pickup to, Oh hell yeah. 100%.
That's totally true. It's, listen, dude,
you're married an American man. I'm
out of it. You don't understand.
If you want to get laid, you got to talk
nonsense to people. Well, I'm a Scorpio.
If you're a Taurus, we should just stop
because I miss that. I misled myself.
I thought it was fading,
but Nancy Reagan was the big proponent.
It's nonsense astrology.
Now it's not like someone who really
understands astrological charts and can
plot it and the moon's in retrograde and
you were born and you know Celsius is
rising and all that crazy crap that they
try to, I don't know what they're doing.
I was on a talk show with finished
Roger a real one. Apparently. Yeah, she,
she's real or fake one,
right?
She says she's real okay.
And I trust her because she talks
about how fake other astrologers are.
There's a hater. She say,
Hey, don't trust her.
And she was saying that the Kennedys
all died during a lunar eclipse.
Scary. And you know that this
is a very checkable statement.
She just says this and everyone's
listening and believing said, wow,
that can't be by accident. Well, I
don't know when other Kennedy's died,
but I know when Jack Kennedy
died and it was November 22nd,
1963 so I don't need to know if there
was an eclipse then I just need to know
what phase the moon is in.
Right.
Cause you can only have a lunar
eclipse when the moon is full.
So the moon was nowhere near full.
It was like two weeks away from full.
Even if it wasn't a clips,
it didn't happen during an
eclipse is my point. Right.
Okay. So of course because it
was daylight. Well when are,
you can have a lunar eclipse
at any time. Okay. You can,
it's solar look anytime too. It's
just dark. It's just not for you.
It would be for your world. Right, right.
Don't be so it's so centric centric.
Um, in fact, when there's a lunar eclipse,
anyone on the side of the earth that sees
the moon, we'll see the lunar eclipse.
So the, so by the way, lunar
eclipses, you get several per year,
by the way.
A partial eclipses as a minimum and every
couple of years there's a full lunar
eclipses. So these are not rare things
to start. They're not rare. Okay.
So I said, you know, he was shot
when the, I forgot what Muna was,
first quarter moon, and she
said, oh, well this counts.
If they're anywhere within two
weeks on either side of the eclipse,
why that's a month out of 12.
What does it side?
Let me just shut up here and let
her keep, it was, what did she say?
Sharing the time. It was a ferrel
had a talk. Should we were both so,
and he likes science by the way. And he,
he wore the NASA shirt at the, uh, at the,
at the Academy Award, um, group photo.
So I've got to give him some
props for that. But, so,
but, so I just say I'm, I'm,
I have nothing more to say here.
Hence my arguing with her
lasted less than five minutes.
Okay.